-Far-right congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
joked over the weekend
that if she
and former Trump adviser
Steve Bannon
had been in charge of the
insurrection on January 6th,
they would have been armed
and they would have won.
The comments come
as Greene prepares
to take on an influential role
in the new GOP majority
in the House.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
As we've been discussing
for the past few weeks,
the GOP performance
in November's midterm elections
was one of the worst outcomes
for an opposition party
in the last 100 years
of American politics.
For example, not a single
Democratic incumbent
in the Senate lost re-election,
despite running in battleground
states like Georgia, Nevada,
New Hampshire, and Arizona.
In fact...
That's right, the last time
Republicans did this badly
was the Great Depression,
and a great depression is where
Donald Trump now finds himself.
The dude -- The dude
is a recluse now.
He doesn't go anywhere.
Spends all his time moping
around his Palm Beach hotel
like a ghost from
a Stephen King novel
where the ghost's too lazy
to scare anyone.
[ As Trump ] Here's Donald.
And also, boo.
Boo, as they say. Boo.
Did I scare you?
Did you hear me?
Did you hear me
lumbering down the hallway
with loose change jangling in
the pockets of my giant coat?
You're not scared at all?
Well, that's too bad, because
my head is stuck in this door.
So if you wouldn't mind,
could you butter up my neck
so I can slip out
and be on my way?
Also, redrum.
We love redrum, don't we, folks?
People say
it's "murder" backwards.
I don't see it.
[ Normal voice ]
The GOP performance was so bad
that even Donald Trump,
a man who craves the spotlight
more than he craves food
and water --
or I guess food and Diet Coke --
has essentially been forced
into isolation,
as "The Washington Post"
reported...
And you know what?
Fine.
He's a 76-year-old former
business idiot from Queens.
That's what he should be doing,
playing golf in Florida
and watching "Yellowstone"
on an 80-inch TV
with his remotes Velcroed
to the coffee table.
This is what
keeps him preoccupied.
Just shuttling him
back and forth
between his golf course
and Mar-a-Lago,
that's a win for everyone.
Hell, let's use taxpayer dollars
to build a high-speed rail line
that only he can use,
or if a high-speed rail
is too expensive,
we can just put cannons
on each side of the lake
to launch him back and forth.
Also, I want to emphasize again,
Trump's isolation started
after he announced he was
running for president again.
It's one thing to say,
"I just lost my re-election bid.
I'm going to take some time
to myself,"
and then go into seclusion.
But it's crazy to do it
after announcing
you're running for the most
powerful office in the world.
Probably just lies
in bed all day
with noise-canceling
headphones on
listening to his old speeches.
-I know windmills very much.
They're noisy.
They kill the birds.
You want to see
a bird graveyard?
Go under a windmill someday.
-Melania standing at the door
trying to get him
to come out for dinner.
"Donald, you have to eat.
You have to eat, Donald.
When I try and slide
the hamburger under the door,
the top of the bun comes off.
It's getting ketchup
all over the door, Donald."
So now Republicans are trying
to figure out what happened.
Some are playing the blame game
and pointing fingers
at each other.
For example, conservatives
have been saying they lost
because they don't use
mail balloting like Democrats,
although they can't quite
seem to figure out
whose fault that is.
-We need to not just
compete for votes, for ballots.
We need to compete for ballots.
If we don't bank ballots early,
we're going to keep losing.
-We didn't.
-But we didn't.
-But we didn't do it in 2020
'cause everyone said don't vote
early 'cause that's corrupt.
-Not everyone.
-Well, a lot of people did
at the very top
of the Republican Party.
-I think Republicans have been
unwilling, for whatever reason,
reluctant, resistant to voting
early and voting by mail.
-Is it really a mystery
to you guys?
These two would make
such terrible detectives
on "Law & Order."
"Weird, this guy's just lying on
the floor for whatever reason.
Excuse me, sir.
Who murdered you?
He's not going to talk.
This is going to be
a tough nut to crack."
But now that more data
is coming in
about who voted in the midterms,
it turns out Republicans didn't
actually have a turnout problem.
They had a candidate problem.
Even Republican voters
couldn't bring themselves
to vote for Republican
candidates, and you know why?
They all tried to be Trump,
but only Trump can be Trump.
Yes, Trump is
a monstrous sociopath,
but he was able to conceal
that reality from some voters
by also being a sweaty,
bumbling oaf
who would ramble about
sexy New York yacht parties
in the '80s to an audience
of Boy Scouts
or dance to the Village People
when he went onstage
and complain nonstop at rallies
about how low water pressure
was causing America's toilets
not to flush.
That same shtick doesn't work
for other Republicans
or other Democrats or literally
any other human being alive.
Like remember
Herschel Walker's weird rant
about vampires and werewolves
that turned off so many voters?
-The other night,
I was watching this movie.
I was watching this movie called
"Fright Night," "Freak Night,"
some type of night,
but it was about vampires.
I don't know if you know,
vampires some cool people,
are they not?
But I'm going to tell you
something that I found out.
A werewolf can kill a vampire.
Did you know that?
I never knew that, so I didn't
want to be a vampire anymore.
I wanted to be a werewolf.
-When Walker said that, everyone
was like, "What the [bleep]"
But if you imagine Trump
doing the same bit,
you can almost see it working.
[ As Trump ] The other night
I was watching "Freak Night"
or "Fright Night"
or some kind of night.
We all love the freaks and
the frights, don't we, folks?
And it was about vampires,
and I said to myself,
"Vampires are some cool people,
are they not?"
It's so true, and you're
hearing it more and more.
Some of my best friends
are vampires, except...
...except the one I know
loves garlic.
It's funny.
It's the opposite.
But then I found out
werewolves can kill vampires.
The fake news,
they won't tell you that.
They want you to think vampires
are more powerful than
werewolves, but it's a hoax.
Because the sun comes out
every day,
but it's very tricky
to find a silver bullet,
because every bullet
looks silver,
but then you shoot the werewolf
and it keeps coming.
You say, "Uh-oh.
I don't think that bullet
was silver."
It's very unfair.
It's very unfair
when you get the bullet
that looks silver
but isn't silver.
Very unfair
how they're treating me.
How they're treating me with
the bullets that look silver
that aren't silver.
Of course, my favorite werewolf
is my son Don Jr.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Republicans
thought they could keep
just doing Trump's routine,
but even their own voters
rejected it,
resulting in yet another
repudiation at the ballot box
and a historic performance
by Democrats.
And yet some of the GOP's
most prominent politicians
are still leaning further in
the direction of MAGA extremism
after it was rejected by voters.
Georgia congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
for example, appeared at
a Republican gala in Manhattan
over the weekend
and apparently decided
that one of the biggest issues
facing Americans right now
is the availability of sex toys
at department stores.
Yeah, no one wants to hear
about butt plugs and dildos
during dessert,
especially on a night
when the dessert
is banana split.
[ Laughter ]
Also, even if they do
sell those items,
I can't imagine
they're easy to get.
I mean, you can't even
pick up toothpaste at CVS
without pushing a little button
and waiting for
the world's sleepiest person
to shuffle over
and unlock the case.
Can you imagine going in for
a dildo and pushing the button?
[ Ding ]
-Customer needs help
in the dildo aisle.
-It's not for me.
It's not for my wife, either.
She's very satisfied.
It's for, um...
It's for a secret Santa thing
at the office.
Yeah, I look like Seth Meyers.
I hear that a lot, but I'm not.
I get that a lot.
I think a lot of people
look like him.
And let's not forget this person
is going to have actual power
in the House GOP majority
next year.
GOP leader Kevin McCarthy
has essentially made a pact
with Greene and other extremists
to keep them happy
and let them run wild
in exchange for their votes.
And part of that pact
means she'll be allowed
to serve on committees again,
which she was barred from doing
by Democrats
after a series of bigoted
and inflammatory remarks.
-Marjorie Taylor Greene
said she wants a seat
on the Oversight Committee.
Are you okay with that?
Will you support that
despite her history
of inflammatory remarks,
denying the 2020 election?
-Look, Marjorie Greene, if she's
going to get re-elected,
she's going to have committees
to serve on.
Marjorie Greene is going to
have committees, yes.
She's duly elected
by her district
and has a right to serve.
-I'm looking forward
to Republicans taking back
control in the House.
And I'm lookin' forward
to serving on committees.
-It's definitely a red flag
anytime someone says the words
"I'm looking forward
to serving on committees"
with that much devious glee.
She's got the energy
of a PTA president
who's going to use her power
to blackmail her enemies.
"That's right, Pam.
I'm back on
the bake sale committee,
and everyone thinks
your gluten-free brownies
taste like a..."
-Butt plug or a dildo.
-"Hope I didn't ruin
your dessert, Pam."
Also, what's with the shades,
Officer Cartman?
She looks like someone
who would try to pull you over
despite not being a cop.
"Do you know how fast
you were going?"
"Yeah, like 45 in a 50."
"Well, I need you
to speed it up.
I got committee meetings
to get to."
Somehow, that was not
the most bizarre thing
Greene said at the gala.
She also joked that if she
and Trump ally Steve Bannon,
who was also present
at the event,
had been in charge
of the attempt
to overturn the election results
on January 6th,
they would have won because
they would have had weapons.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Crowd shouting ]
You see, the joke is,
conservatives are such
blood-thirsty psychopaths,
if they had actually planned
the insurrection on the Capitol,
it would have been
way more violent.
That's like if Holiday Inn
ran an ad that said...
Now, let me just say,
if I saw Greene with a gun,
I would definitely be scared,
but I refuse to believe
Steve Bannon
knows how to use one.
No one who layers polo shirts
is good with a firearm.
In a way, they'd make fun
partners in a buddy-cop movie.
You could call it...
-Butt plug.
-...and...
-Dildo.
-"Butt Plug, Dildo,
in my office now!
You two are a real
pain in my ass."
Voters, including Republicans,
made it clear in November
that they're tired
of all the MAGA weirdness
and pro-Trump extremism.
If the MAGA movement
was a political winner,
Trump would be out there
taking a victory lap right now.
Instead he's lying around
his bedroom like an unused...
-Dildo.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]